- Well let's talk about some favorites.
So what inspired "The Dance?"
- I was sittin' at The Bluebird,
there was probably about
seven or eight of us,
there was this guy named Tony Arata
was sittin' there playin' and
Tony starts in on this song
and when he gets done
with it I'm just amazed
and nobody in the room
seems to be gettin' the same
reaction that I'm getting.
And so I take it to Allen Reynolds,
Allen Reynolds says he
loves it and we keep waitin'
and keep waitin' and
finally Allen Reynolds goes,
"How come we haven't cut "The Dance" yet?
'Cause the album was almost over.
I said, "I'm not sure
that it's country enough."
- What?
- You know, 'cause this
bein' from Oklahoma
and it had piano in it, which you know,
I had moved to Nashville,
didn't know what a piano was,
'cause it's always just
steels and fiddles.
- Yes but your voice is country music.
- Thank you.
- You tie it in.
- It's funny, 'cause that's what he said.
And he told me, he said,
"Pal, I'm gonna tell you right now,"
he always used the word pal, he says,
"If you don't cut 'The Dance',
if you don't record that song,
it'll be the biggest hit you never had.
- Oh wow.
- It's cool.
- Challenge accepted.
- Yeah, it's just,
what's the, oh thank you.
♪ Lookin' back on the- ♪
- Quit, don't do that!
- I have to do it!
(Garth laughs)
I am literally, like I
can't believe my life!
(Garth laughing)
Like, April, Beck and Mary McConnell,
all my friends from
childhood hate me right now!
I'm so sorry April.
She's the one that introduced you to me!
And I like, I feel like
I'm stealing her moment.